ewiges leben der wohl älteste und
größte wunschtraum der menschen und
das natürlich am besten ohne graue
haare falten im gesicht krankheiten und
andere begleiterscheinungen des alters
wie die forschung den tod für immer
besiegen will welche mechanismen und
sind körper altern lassen und wie wir
auch selbst dafür sorgen können und
jung und fit zu halten jetzt den klicks
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
die große frage die es zu klären gilt
lautet was genau macht uns alle dazu
gibt es verschiedene wissenschaftliche
thesen fest steht das zelluläre
veränderungen den alterungsprozess
beeinflussen
die nobelpreisträgerin elizabeth
blackburn sieht die telomere als
schlüssel eigentlich fungieren sie an
den enden der chromosomen wie
schutzkappen doch mit der zeit nutzen
sie ab wenn sie nicht mehr richtig
funktionieren erhöht sich das risiko
dass der körper erkrankt an den
typischen haupt krankheiten des alterns
wie diabetes krebs oder herz
kreislauferkrankungen medizinisch sind
wir noch nicht in der lage die abnutzung
der telomere zuverlässig zu stoppen
oder sie wieder zu reparieren ja andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dagegen sehen die kommunikation der
zellen untereinander und die daraus
resultierende steuerung von funktionen
im körper als die entscheidende
grundlage der verschiedenen
alterungsprozesse denn wenn signalwege
die im gesunden körper beispielsweise
reparaturmechanismen auslösen gestört
sind führe dies zu krebs diabetes und
autoimmunerkrankungen und es gibt
tatsächlich die versuche die nahelegen
dass alterungsprozess verlangsamt werden
können indem gestörter signalwege
modifiziert werden
wenn man über das altern spricht kommt
man auch um den themenbereich
stammzellen kaum herum im letzten jahr
gab es eine vielbeachtete studie eines
kalifornischen forschungsteams im labor
hatte es mäuse gezüchtet die vorzeitig
alterten die frage des versuchs war kann
dieser alterungsprozess im nachhinein
gebremst werden in ihren zellen
aktivierte das forschungsteam dann die
sogenannten yamanaka faktoren diese
sitzen sind sonst nur im stamm zell
stadium aktiv die gene wurden über eine
längere zeit immer für nur zwei tage
pro woche an
das ergebnis die labormäuse lebten
nicht nur ein drittel länger
sie entwickelten auch keine
krebserkrankung ja das forschungsteam
behandelte zudem auch ältere gesunde
mäuse auf diese art und weise die
wunden dieser mäuse verhalten schneller
sie wirkten nach der behandlung jünger
und ja der studienleiter juan carlos in
spa belmonte sagt dazu zitat unsere
studie zeigt dass alter nicht
zwangsläufig in eine richtung
voranschreiten muss der prozess ist
vielmehr form war und kann bei
sorgfältiger regulierung wahrscheinlich
umgekehrt werden zitat ende ja wahnsinn
doch fest steht auch dass diese
ergebnisse nicht eins zu eins auf uns
menschen übertragen werden können und
doch die visionen der wissenschaft sind
gigantisch die methusalems stiftung in
virginia will es in zukunft schaffen
dass menschen biologisch gesehen für
immer bei einem alter von 25 jahren
bleiben können
90 jährige sollten so gesund bleiben
die 40 jahre jüngere die biotechnologie
macht immer mehr fortschritte in
richtung ewiges leben unterstützt durch
viel geld der pharmaindustrie das time
magazin hatte 2013 gefragt kangoo
geläuf des also kann google den tod
aufhalten vorher hatte der digital
konzern google nämlich seine tochter
kaliko gegründet um mit 1,5 milliarden
dollar eine antwort auf genau diese
frage zu finden
die hälfte der finanzierung aber ein
pharmaunternehmen dazu steuert auch das
silicon valley milliardär larry ellison
ist ein jahr todes gegner muss man sagen
und hofft dass viel geld zu zahlreichen
wissenschaftlichen entdeckungen führt
die dann in kombination mit besseren
heilmethoden unser leben verlängern
können bis das zur realität wird kann
aber auch jeder einzelne selbst dafür
sorgen die qualität seines eigenen
lebens zu verbessern
denn im besten fall erhöht dies auch
die lebensdauer forschungsteams weltweit
verweisen immer wieder darauf dass
meditation ja zum beispiel stress
reduzieren kann und viel stress
beschleunigt die biologische alterung
das sagen viele studien und jetzt gibt
es noch ein geschenk für euch in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion von
technology review der zeitschrift ist
dieses video entstanden und exklusiv
für klicks um zuschauer gibt es jetzt
eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen
link geklickt es lohnt sich kann ich nur
sagen technology review ist wirklich
mega spannend ja und hier geht es zu
einem weiteren wie
dass wir mit der redaktion gemacht haben
virtual reality verändert die welt auch
sehr spannend unbedingt drauf klicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran